[Music]  it's hard to have a fresh start when the  past is on your mind I think we have  some unfinished business to talk about  but it's a new me  [Music]  we'll Bettelheim your credit came back  sparkling well I like to I do not on the  socials that you might be some kind of  freak I'm told  la is what you make of it  who you surround yourself with  [Music]  hello you love it's nice to meet you  love maybe I should run but I don't want  to what are your intentions with my  sister  perfect bite project  [Music]  what do you want Candace you did it  again didn't you  this is about your ex's name  she really hurt you  [Music]  if he loves you that's the most  dangerous thing  I won't let this situation go bad  nothing is ok without you  be whatever you want you're so very  special I wish I was special  [Music]